guess who's back well you probably don't
need to be told since it's almost
guaranteed that you and everyone you
know has been freaking out about his
return as since the moment the Avengers
and game trailer drops yeah you guessed
it it's Hawkeye what you see that coming
one person who was only just recently
addressed in Barton's return to the
Marvel Cinematic Universe is the man
behind the foe himself Jeremy Renner
sure the actor has been teasing fans for
months on end the Bowser's connection to
the fourth Avengers film posting plenty
of cheeky snaps on Instagram with
Avengers related captions but Ranna has
mostly kept quiet about how exactly
Hawkeye will fit into the upcoming
movies story that'll change when Marvel
Studios rolled out the trailer for
endgame which revealed Renner back in
action not as Hawkeye
but as Hawkeye zolturi go ronan after
the trailer debuted Renner took to
Twitter to share the footage that Marvel
had released that morning posting to his
four million followers good to see you
all again coming in Harts Ranna that had
it to his Instagram account and uploaded
the teaser poster for the film which
confirmed the movies earlier than
expected release date of April 26 2019
Brenna's caption read anyone seen the
trailer obviously does kind of a silly
question considering and games trailer
set a new record by racking up 289
million views in the first 24 hours
after its release when Marvel fans first
learned that Hawkeye and Ant Man
wouldn't appear in Avengers infinity war
the rumor mill began to crank out fun
Theory after fan theory regarding their
unknown whereabouts Infinity Ward did
offer a brief explanation but it was
pretty blinken your Missa
where's Clint after the whole accord
situation he and Scott took a deal was
too tough on their families aren't house
arrest after Thanos loaded up the
Infinity Gauntlet with all six Infinity
stones snapped his fingers and wiped out
half the universe in the final moments
of infinity war fans started to freak
and who can blame them
audiences watched as beloved heroes like
Scarlet Witch star-lords spider-man
black panther and many more faded into
dusty nothingness were still Hawkeye
enhancements fates were less and clearer
since they weren't present on the
battlefield and so audiences were left
to wonder one of those two heroes have
become victims of the decimation since
infinity wars ending we thankfully
learned that both Clint Barton and Scott
still alive the end credits scene of
ant-man and the wasp confirm Scott Lang
survival albeit in a perilous state
stuck in the quantum realm of no obvious
means of escape
after a long wait the end game trailer
confirmed that Hawkeye also survived the
decimation
but while ant-man seemed relatively good
spirits in endgame Hawkeye is a
different story
suited up as Ronin he looks as sleek as
he does intimidating and it's evident
that he's gone through exactly the kind
of trauma that would push someone to
transform into a rogue assassin Steve
Rogers stating that the heroes lost
friends family and a part of themselves
following infinity war in place
Hawkeye's family may have disintegrated
in the snap spurring him into becoming
Ronin this is just a rumor for now but
infinity warrant and game directors Joe
and Anthony Russo had previously
promised to cook up something special
for Hawkeye inertia stretched throughout
shooting on endgame Rena had been
generous with behind-the-scenes teasers
often uploading selfies taken on set in
June the actor teased on Instagram got
this feeling I need to suit up soon
Renner also turned things up a notch
when he uploaded a photo of himself from
the last day of filming on endgame and
while his re-emergence and the franchise
was all but inevitable it's nice to know
that Renner can now talk a little more
openly about Avengers endgame
[Music]